Doug Flutie NBC Sports lead analyst for
Notre Dame football won the Heisman 1984
of course former NFL and CFL college
football legend and they have relaunched
Flutie flakes when these first came out
they sold two million boxes when he was
playing I believe with the Buffalo Bills
proceeds benefit the Doug Flutie
Foundation supporting autism which
afflicts his son Doug jr. and Doug will
be in attendance for the Heisman Trophy
presentation in New York City tomorrow
night Doug Flutie joining us on the
program where is the Heisman right now
Doug where's my ice and my Heisman is in
a little trophy room set up downstairs
and it's there's no on a pedestal kind
of display but tucked away we see it
every now and then we go to visit just
to make sure it doesn't get left alone
but it's yeah the school gets one I get
one so I have one at home and there's
one at the school as well
Carson Palmer sent me his Heisman Trophy
he sent it to you so you have it as a
background backdrop for you for the show
yeah yeah he sent it to read does this
mean this is just setting a precedent is
that I'm I'm just saying if you want to
I'm not saying you have to I'm just
saying Carson Palmer sent me his -
trophy well I hate my life guard medals
off of my eyes so you know that's you
know the important stuff he's got to go
over there with the Heisman and hang off
the arm
we actually I have a Sports Bar and
Grill up in the Foxboro area plane
routes park because you know that that I
take the Heisman occasionally put it up
there for about six months at a time
near the restaurant but other net it's
usually home my wife my wife is very
clingy and does not want it roaming too
much if not Boston College where where
were you going to go chances were I was
an Ivy League kid I was talking Harvard
at Brown but then I also got an offer
from UNH I was talking about University
New Hampshire because I really needed a
scholarship I was in a position where I
needed a scholarship and Boston College
came into picture real late because I
had a coaching change and all that so I
was very fortunate to get a Division one
author did you play at less point your
senior year definitely did play at West
Point because I think I was there that
night you had four touchdown passes
against them yeah that was my freshman
year at West Point it was like my second
start and I had started the week before
or two weeks earlier I started against
Navy we got beat I played really well
against a top ranked Pitt team and that
was my third start at army it was my
first you know breakout performance big
game I'm also curious about this I don't
know if you face this but we were just
looking at don't like there's lists
there like the least deserving Heisman
winners and I think we attached how you
perform as a pro whether or not you were
worthy of the Heisman Trophy as a
college player do you find that that
their people have a hard time separating
the two yeah my situation I mean not
with you but I'm just saying that like
Jason White at Oklahoma Gino Torretta
like their names always come up in art
right it doesn't take away from what
they did over those four years what they
did that senior year or whatever year
was they happen to win you know they led
a team so much as team oriented and I
say this even today you know we look at
the greatest athletes and they're
phenomenal it would like be a tailback
might be a defensive back but if they're
not in the mix or a national
championship more so today than even
back then they're not even considered
you've got to be almost undefeated one
loss at best and you know to get in that
mix and and you know those guys that
didn't have successful pro careers they
they led their teams they did what was
necessary under the circumstances and
you know set themselves apart so you
know I have no problem with that you
know there's certain guys that didn't
play at all and you know it just those
things happened something you know there
is something to be said for the scheme
you know certain quarterbacks get in the
scheme they're throwing all these wide
receiver screens they get ten thousand
yards passing yeah you know there there
are some parts of it that are skewed but
for the most part you're picking
guys that have had tremendous years and
led their teams to whether it's a
national championship or not in the mix
he's Doug Flutie won the Heisman Trophy
in 1984 joining us on behalf of Flutie
flakes a cereal that sold over 2 million
boxes when he was playing who came up
with that idea of Flutie flakes uh it
was an endorsement opportunity for for
me with Petey I'll be sports and they
had done they had done like a Mario
Lemieux peanut butter or something and
salsa and the most units ate sold of
anything was like two hundred thousand
and that was kind of the benchmark that
we were hoping to get and all of a
sudden it over select the perfect storm
there was just an endorsement thing I
had and then when I got the Buffalo I
started the foundation so we figured all
the proceeds towards the foundation and
it just took off and I just happened I
started playing at the time it was a
perfect storm it just really was and it
exploded of course chris burrman eating
them on Monday Night Football kind of
help I'm also curious what you think
like if you were at Boston College and
you were winning the Heisman Trophy this
year how do you how different would it
be you know help teams would look at you
as a professional quarterback
yeah it's night and day now with all the
spread offenses and the undersized
quarterbacks that are having success and
yeah I'm very jealous at the game today
a lot of the stuff that's going on right
now in the NFL is stuff we did in Canada
for those eight years I was up in Canada
complete spread offenses quarterback
design runs quarterback zone read type
stuff within run pass options off of we
were doing all that stuff in the 90s up
in Canada and it yeah I get a little
jealous of that but those out what were
you 11th round draft pick I was an 11th
round draft pick because I'd already
signed
I was projected anywhere from a first to
a fourth no and I signed with the New
Jersey generals Donald Trump and I was
under contract for six years so just
towards the end of the draft as it was
coming around the Rams picked up my
rights but I was still under contract
for another four or five years in the
USFL
when the USFL folded then the Rams had
already directed Jim Everett the next
year traded my rights over to Chicago
and I went to Chicago I think I was at
your introductory press conference at
Trump Tower but did it have the
waterfall behind and then it was hard to
pick up the what you were saying on the
microphone because that the waterfall
was was really loud in Trump Tower yeah
I just remember I don't know how the how
the audio was in there but I remember
the waterfall behind me it was just an
atrium yeah there's levels of reporters
and cameras and it was a zoo and you
know they did it in a big way and did
you don't I'm in the USFL I did I got
paid on time I'll tell you what that's
the one thing I'll say about Trump when
he was an owner
we were run like an NFL franchise
there's no doubt about it we got paid we
had good facilities we were at the
Meadowlands we had to show them all that
I got paid now there was a guaranteed
portion of it that when the league
folded that he negotiated down to free
me you know to let me let me go play in
the NFL so the other result there was I
got all the money that was coming to me
even though some was negotiated down
because I wanted to go play in the NFL
and then you got a chance to get yelled
at by Mike Ditka oh yeah that's always
fun
yeah everything that I was there for to
McMahon had a shoulder surgery and was
struggling and Ditka didn't really
believe in the quarterbacks he had so he
brought me in the end of the year and I
was like on a fast I was there for ten
days and I was starting a game and it
was like plays the plays on a wristband
you're the hardest part the hardest part
was that he had the old Dallas system
and evens were left and odds were yeah
odds to the right and evens left which
is opposite of every system that you'd
ever just calling a running play made me
stop and hesitate and think it was yeah
that was torture oh god he just I don't
know what it was he just did did Kay
ever like any of his quarterbacks you
know the only
guy that could play for him was Jim
McMahon because he'd give it right back
no you had that kind of mentality and
and Ditka liked me we got along great
bet on game day he was just you know
really a little bit hot-headed and won
it got you've got frustrated and yelling
and you know as a quarterback I always
loved the coach to wrap his arm around
you give you confidence go out take some
risk and turn it loose so under a guy
like dick all of a sudden you're
paranoid to make a mistake you're being
careful with the football all that so a
guy like Jim McMahon who just you know
Turner give it right back to him Jim
just went out and bawled and he'd played
and and he you had to have that kind of
personality to be successful for him
Joe Burrell is certainly an interesting
quarterback that from the standpoint of
he's it kind of had an overnight success
even though it's not really overnight
success we had Rick Neuheisel on a
couple of weeks ago and he said he's
he's a more athletic Tom Brady and at
the time I went whoa slow the praise
there but can you can you see that or is
that being unfair to Joe burrow and Tom
Brady as much as I love Tom Brady
yes Joe's more athletic but you know
you'll have a long way to go to get the
word Thomas but he's got those kind of
skills he really does and I don't know
if we're all just getting so carried
away because we've never seen this at
LSU this is right you know I worry about
that because I I mean I think the world
of them I didn't AMA know quarterback
he's had an unbelievable year everything
you know making making plays carrying
the teams all that stuff but then it
gets magnified because we're used to
seeing them go up against Alabama and
play at 9 to 6 game this year was 50
something to 40 something and they're
scoring points every week and flinging
it around the field but so that's there
you know it's just a different element
that we've never seen out of LSU so it
gets magnified how great he is Beth and
Lamar Jackson I think you know there's a
lot of teams that could have drafted him
and then Baltimore almost missed out on
drafting him in the first round and
getting that you know on that rookie
5-year deal here so what what is it
about Lamar Jackson that everybody was
missing out on
you know it's the fear of the guy that's
just run the spread stuff and in college
you've always had this impression that
NFL quarterback and you do you have to
know your past protections you have to
be able to read the entire field you go
back in in my day you you had a
universal route and you read coverage
and that dictated where you're going
with ball depending on coverage and then
your progression start at one two three
in that area now they are all used to
being in the right place right coverage
because of double cadence and dummy
cadence stuff and thrown these wide
receiver screens and then the
quarterback run stuff it's not as much
of that full sealed real read and then
spread offenses it the guys weren't
always carrying over to the NFL and
having success and there's a little bit
of a fear factor there you know Kenny
stand there and throw the difference is
Lamar is a phenomenal athlete but he can
throw the ball down the field he can
make the one-on-one throws and you've
got to be able to you've got to be able
to win both ways you've got to be able
to win from the pocket because
eventually teams are going to figure out
how to take the other stuff away and
make you beat them with the things that
you don't do well and so they're therein
lies the fear you know is he going to be
able to beat you from the top hey Doug
have a good weekend there and congrats
on the Flutie flakes part 2 here
benefiting the Doug Flutie foundation
supporting autism which afflicts his son
Doug jr. of course many others and he'll
be at the Heisman Trophy ceremony
tomorrow night
thank you Doug great to talk to you
again appreciate it Dan thank you so
much for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]